hi my name is Jacob Malaysia I represent
Malaysia engineering Limited we build
infrastructure projects across the
country and the question that was asked
to me is the role of CEOs in India
versus the CEOs overseas a very good
question now the difference between the
CEOs the way they run their show over
here is value we have an inclusive value
methodology of running the companies
which means what it means the value not
only for the stakeholder that is your
investors and your bankers but also the
value of the social society within this
the area that we operate because
infrastructure gets you to the deep
parts of the country where the people do
not have all the benefits that the other
people have so it's inclusive the other
values that are different from the CEOs
overseas versus the CEOs over here is a
family value the good part about the
Indian philosophy and religion which is
quite deep is the family values has
still remained very strong and intact
that's why if you see the major
corporations that are listed in the
stock exchange sill substantial of them
are listed but a huge amount of family
control so it's a good inclusive growth
of values that differentiate between the
Western CEOs and the Indian CEOs as I
see